in a haze of teargas handful of
protestors stand their ground as
hundreds more flee the streets of
Columbia's capital Bogota we've become
the backdrop to fierce anti-government
demonstrations on Thursday the violence
left three people dead on a day a
quarter of a million people marched on
the city the response from president
even decay has been firm a few minutes
ago
a supreme commander of the military
forces and police and in coordination
with the mayor of Bogota Enrique
peñalosa we have set a curfew that
curfew kicks in each night at 9 p.m.
with key areas off limits from 8 o'clock
the grievances focus on rumors of
economic reform denied by the President
as well as anger and what is seen as a
government failure to crack down on
corruption and the murder of human
rights activists
we came to protest peacefully said one
demonstrator we came his flowers with
banners
we are received with tear gas thousands
had gathered on Friday afternoon in the
city's Bolivar Plaza banging pots and
pans for a traditional casserole a so a
Latin American expression of political
discontent but it descended into chaos
businesses shut up shop a sporadic
looting broke out
we are not vandals reads the sign held
aloft by a frustrated protester the
action in Colombia is the latest in a
tide of political unrest across South
America in Bogota troops are ensuring
the nighttime restrictions are enforced
it'll take more than a curfew to quash
such anger Emma Birchley Sky News